Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Du möchtest, hast Themenvorschläge. Ich hab gestern auf Twitter schon gefragt. Hat jemand Themenvorschläge? Eine Frage war, was trägt Wolfgang beim Sport?
Ich glaube, das interessiert die Leute jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Trainingsanzug.
Nein, ich glaube, es interessiert die Leute eher, dass wir keinen Finanzminister mehr haben.
Haben wir einen Verlust?
Auf keinen Fall. Ich hoffe, er beantragt kein Bürgergeld.
Kein Finanzminister ist kein Verlust.
Kein Finanzminister ist kein Verlust. Das ist ganz deutlich so zu sehen. Ich bin nicht wahnsinnig überrascht, aber bin überrascht darüber, wie schnell es dann plötzlich ging, wie schnell es sich dann hochgeschaukelt hat, so an einem späten Nachmittag bis hin zum Abend. Und ich bin entsetzt darüber, dass es jetzt so eskaliert ist, allerdings habe ich auf dein Geheiß hin einen Podcast mir angehört und angesehen, in dem Christian Lindner zu Gast war, nämlich im Hotel Matze. Und ich verfolge hin und wieder Hotel Matze. Manchmal sind Politiker da, dann ist mir das oft sehr menschend und dann interessiert mich da nicht so sehr. Dann ist jemand da wie Barbara Bleich, die wunderbar aus ihrem Leben und aus ihrer Philosophie erzählen kann. Und man merkt tatsächlich, es entsteht ein Gespräch zwischen zwei Menschen oder H. P. Kerkeling. Da findet das dann auch statt, obwohl es zwei Medienprofis sind. Sieht man plötzlich, dass sich da Menschen verständigen, nochmal einen Begriff definieren, bereit sind zu zögern, um nachzudenken, um dann näher zu einer wahrheitsgemäßen Antwort zu kriegen. Und all das ist das Interview mit Christian Lindner nicht. Man sieht das und ist wirklich erschrocken darüber. Und ich muss mich ja hier vorsichtig ausdrücken, weil wir haben hier sehr viel darüber gesprochen, wie Trump so tickt. Ja, Lindner hat einen anderen Stil als Trump. Aber wir haben schon sehr viel über die besondere psychische Struktur von Macht Menschen gesprochen. Und man braucht, glaube ich, nur mal drei, vier Minuten in dieses Interview reinzuschalten, um zu sehen, hier sitzt ein Mensch, der einen Charakter hat, mit dem man eigentlich nichts zu tun haben will. Und zwar nicht auf einer politischen Ebene, nicht auf einer privaten Ebene, auf gar keiner Ebene. Ich bin so entsetzt darüber, was ich da sehe. Also wie sich dort ein Mensch verhält, wie präpotent er dort sitzt, wie er keinerlei Zweifel an sich aufkommen lässt, wie er überhaupt alles herunterbügelt. Und man muss wissen, Matze Hilscher ist ja jemand, der wohlgesonnen einem jeden Gast gegenüber sitzt. Vielleicht manchmal zu wohlgesonnen, nach meinem Geschmack, ja. Also man kann eigentlich aus einem Matze Hilscher-Gespräch gar nicht schlecht herauskommen. Es ist eigentlich der Ort, an dem man sich wieder ja von einer guten Seite zeigen kann. Also wenn man irgendwas Böses gemacht hat, geht man zu Matze Hilscher und sagt, ich bin aber jetzt ein anderer geworden oder so. Und man hat einen Christian Lindner da, der wirklich völlig frei dreht. Und ich fand es beängstigend zu sehen, dass wir von einem solchen Mann regiert werden und war gestern tatsächlich, egal was da jetzt kommen möge, erleichtert, dass dieses Spiel ein Ende hat. Und wenn ich daran denke, dass man als Bundeskanzler mit Christian Lindner regelmäßig zu tun hat, in einem Raum sitzen muss, dann weiß ich gar nicht, wie man das aushält.
Ja, wir haben es ja schon darliegen. Man sieht es auch im Bild, das Verlustbuch von Andreas Reckwitz. Zumindest thematisch. Das erste Wort des Buches ist ein Aufhänger, ein Anlass, sozusagen, um über alles zu reden. Denn Verluste werden doch hart verrechnet. Jetzt hast du schon sehr ausführlich einen Eindruck deines Hörerlebnisses. Lindner bei Matze Hilscher gehört. Ich halte das Gespräch auch für historisch. Es erklärt uns vieles. Nicht nur allgemein Zuhörern, die mit einer Gefühlslage daran gehen wie du und feststellen, krass, ich höre ihn jetzt sozusagen mal länger als zwei Minuten vom Blatt abgelesen. Und ich kann es nicht glauben, was ich hier fühle.
Ja.
So, wir benutzen das jetzt aber als Klammer. Also wir hören Clips daraus gleich. Denn wir müssen erst erklären, warum wir uns besonders für dieses Interview da interessieren. Zum einen ist die große Fragestellung von, wir haben ja sein Buch gelesen, Im Grunde Gut, in der er die Frage stellt, wenn die Menschen doch im Grunde gut sind, warum spült ausgerechnet der politische Betrieb so viele Egoisten, manchmal populär, zuschauerisch als Narzisten, noch gesteigert an die Spitze, warum werden ausgerechnet da, wo das Gemeinwohl angeblich im Mittelpunkt steht, so oft nur particulare Interessen, versteckt, offen formuliert, durchgeprügelt, wie auch immer. Diese Frage kann man sehr gut beantworten, gerade jetzt, nicht nur, weil wir dieses Marzahirischer Gespräch haben, sondern auch noch durch die Ereignisse gestern. Also wir haben auf offener Bühne gesehen, dass ein Bundeskanzler Bilanz zieht eines Verhaltens, das wir schon lange so beobachtet haben, aber das vom Bundeskanzler versteckt werden musste.
Ja, es war eine permanente Devianz da, über die man nicht gesprochen hat.
Ja, dieses Statement von Schulz gestern ist also stellvertretend für aufgestaute Wut, Entrüstung, aufgrund von Beobachtung über drei Jahre, die aus ihm herausbrach. Er hat Christian Lindner mehrfach beim Namen genannt. Er hat von betrügerischen, verräterischen, ich überspitze es so ein bisschen, Verhalten vor Ort gesprochen, Absprachen, die auf Handschlag zugesagt wurden, nur um direkt aus dem Raum zu gehen und in die Kamera zu sagen, das sind die größten Idioten, ich weiß es besser, die Absprache war falsch, wir werden Prüfaufträger und so weiter. Wir werden alles wieder topdieren. So, und jetzt ist das, was gestern passiert ist, aber nur, also es klappte nur, weil gestern noch anderes passiert ist. Also Trump hat die Wahl gewonnen und Christian Lindner wurde entlassen. Und es gab so ein Tenor, der sich fragte, musste das jetzt auch noch sein? Brauchten wir nicht gerade jetzt Stabilität? Und ich würde sagen, nein, nur weil das eine passierte, war das andere möglich. Also es war sozusagen schicksalhaft verwoben, ein Tag, der es so, es fehlte nur noch, dass sie bis zum 9. November warten, so, was alles passierte. Aber ich will es mal in wirklich ein Bild bringen. In Amerika hat sich ein particularistisches, ideologiegetriebenes Interesse direkt in die Macht katapultiert. Und damit meine ich gar nicht so sehr Trump, denn der ist einfach doof, sondern ich meine Elon Musk. Elon Musk ist jetzt der quasi-Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten. Er ist nicht einfach Steve Bannon, der einfach gefeuert werden kann.
Wer weiß, ob Trump dann in drei Monaten das alles anders geht.
Trump kann sich nicht gegen ihn entscheiden, weil er kann ihn wirklich nicht kündigen.
Das stimmt.
Weil Elon Musk nimmt alles mit, was Trump wichtig ist. Den Zugriff auf die Technologie, den Zugriff auf die Märkte und den Zugriff auf das Publikum. Elon Musk gehört Starlink, Elon Musk, das ist quasi die Erpressertechnologie für Taiwan, China und Putin.
Twitter, E-Mobilität wird wichtig werden.
Genau, das sind die Märkte. Wenn du dich gegen China behaupten willst, ich habe die Fabriken dafür.
So viel zu liberalen Demokratie.
Genau. Und wenn du wissen willst, was deine Leute denken, brauchst du Twitter. Also Elon Musk hat Donald Trump auf eine Art und Weise in der Tasche, wie wir es bisher nur kannten, als sich die Kaiser und Fürsten, die Könige, die großen Dynastien, die über Jahrhunderte regierten, plötzlich als, ach so, ich habe Schulden bei den Fuggers. Zack, die ganze Logik der Welt umgedreht, die moderne Statte, der der Kapitalismus begann, usw. usf. Das ist jetzt dieser Moment. Also man darf das sowieso nicht gering schätzen. Also man in Amerika dieses Heranstürmen eines particularen, ideologiegetriebenen, egozentrischen, im Grunde schlechte Seite des Menschen ist jetzt in Amerika installiert. Und Olaf Scholz hat gestern genau das bei Lindner kritisiert und als Begründung genannt, weshalb er gehen muss. Also die Ampel hatte gestern in ihrer letzten Viertelstunde ihren Humanmöhöhepunkt sozusagen.
Und das war ja auch anzumerken, Olaf Scholz. Er hat hier die beste Rede seines Lebens gehalten. Ganz klar, sowohl was die emotionale Tonalität stimmte, die Aussagen stimmten. Es war eine Rede, die sagte, wir haben jetzt eine Krise und welche Krise ist gemeint? Nun, wir haben die Wirtschaftskrise. Wir haben aber vor allem, wir sind dann wenige Stunden nachdem das Wahlergebnis bekannt geworden ist, an einem Punkt angelangt, an dem Trump erneut im Weißen Haus ist. Man sich also fragt, was wird geschehen mit Europa, mit Deutschland. Und wir haben nichts anderes dann erlebt als eine FDP an der Spitze Christian Lindner, die einfach nur ihren Trip weiter verfolgt. Und deswegen will ich auch hier ausdrücklich allen Journalisten, die zuhören, sagen, wer noch Marie-Arknes Strack Zimmermann interviewt, ist unseriös. Die FDP scheißt auf die Ukrainer, ob die in einen harten Winter gehen oder sonst irgendetwas. Der FDP ist auch egal, was jetzt gerade mit NATO und sonst was ist. Das soll jetzt Scholz klären und vielleicht findet er ein Einverständnis mit März. Der FDP ist alles scheißegal, ladet Strack Zimmermann nicht mehr ein. Sie ist nicht bereit, sie wurde auch gestern interviewt, irgendeinen Fehler einzugestehen. Sie macht denselben Muffi Christian Lindner. Es ist unseriös, mit diesen Leuten noch über Verantwortung und schon gerade geopolitische Verantwortung zu sprechen.
Ja, Wolf Schmiese hat im August, ich habe diesen Clip gestern nochmal getwittert, hat im heutigen Journal gesagt, in der SPD warten einige auf den Wahlsieg Donald Trumps, weil dann klar ist, die Ukraine ist verloren. Kein weiterer Euro und Dollar kommt aus Amerika. Und wir wissen jetzt, die Ideologie, die jetzt in Amerika an der Macht ist, ist so scharf, dass sie auch die eigene Rüstungsindustrie unter den Bus wirft. Wir haben das gehört von Tucker Carlson. Lieber verliere ich mein Haus zu Hause, als dass irgendein Afrikaner kommt und mir erklärt, das ist nicht mehr dein Land. So, die eigene Rüstungsindustrie ist dieses eigene Haus. Lieber zieht man sich aus der Welt zurück und sagt, lass uns Bomben bauen, aber hier zu Hause behalten, bevor auch nur und so weiter. Deswegen, ja, die FDP ist so, wie du es gesagt hast. Der ist alles scheißegal und Schulz und Lindner. Sag mal so, Schulz hat gestern ein gut vorbereitetes Statement gehalten und Schulz hat die Schuldenbremse, also er hat gesagt, es ist an der Schuldenbremse zerbrochen. Zwei Punkte. Lindner bezog sich genau auf diese beiden Punkte. Er hat gesagt, Schulz hat ein erstaunlich gut vorbereitetes Statement gehalten, wo ich mir denke, ah ja, Christian Lindner glaubt gerade, indem er Olaf Scholz Professionalität unterstellt, kann er ihm schaden. Ja. Das verstehe ich nicht. Und Lindner hat noch mal auf die Schuldenbremse auch abgestellt, im Sinne von, ich erkenne diese Notlage nicht an.
Und sagte, er hätte dann doch einen Amtseid geschworen und das hat ja nichts mit dem Amtseid zu tun, das war an die Schuldenbremse. Also mir ist neu, dass man sich vereidigen lässt in Deutschland und dann auch noch auf die Schuldenbremse schwört.
Also das ist alles total Hanebüchen. Das heißt, Schulz und Lindner haben gestern quasi inhaltlich dasselbe Statement abgegeben mit den zwei gleichen Schwerpunkten. Aber Lindner hat es aus einer praktikalistischen Interessenlage. Ich kämpfe für die drei Prozent, die mich noch wählen und das sind halt die Leute, die was zu verlieren haben, gehalten und scheiß auf die Ukraine. Und Schulz hat dasselbe gesagt, nur mit umgedrehten Vorzeichen und etwas, wie schon gesagt, angenehmer, professioneller, so dass wir es auch verstehen.
Er sprach von Verantwortung. Er hat die Ukraine mit in den Blick genommen und zugleich aber auch die wirtschaftliche Situation in Deutschland. Er sagte, ich will nicht das eine gegen das andere ausspielen. Das nämlich hat die FDP vor. Und das war ja immer der Vorwurf so vieler Journalisten zu sagen, ja, Alice Weidel und Sarah Wagenknecht, die spielen die Ukraine-Hilfe gegen den Sozialstaat aus, weil sie sagen, entweder das eine oder das andere. Und dann habe ich immer gedacht, bei dieser Argumentation, die Journalisten sowohl vorbrachten, ja, das machen die beiden, aber die FDP macht das ja die ganze Zeit. Die FDP sagt ja, na, so viel Geld ist da, wem wollte das nun geben? Und da sagt Olaf Scholz, jetzt wird man sehen, was daraus folgt, wir wollen jetzt auch nicht glorifizieren hier, sagt aber Olaf Scholz, nein, wir müssen die Schuldenbremse lockern, damit beides geht und es nicht eine entweder-oder-Logik ist. Und der Witz ist ja wirklich, dass Lindner in seinem Statement sofort darauf eingeht, du hast schon gesagt, dass Scholz sein Statement vorbereitet hat.
Besser ist, wenn der Regierung zerbricht, dass man das kurz vorbereitet.
Es ist so, dass diese Leute ja wissen, wie Lindner tickt. Und ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass wir, Wolfgang Schmitt oder so, auch mal Marze Hilscher mal reingeschaltet hat und hat gesagt, hier, Olaf, der dreht völlig frei, guck mal hier kurz rein. Und dann wird Olaf Scholz gesagt haben, bereitet man Statement vor, man weiß ja nicht, was der am Mittwoch vorhat. Ganz genau. Das ist professionelles Handeln. Und ich hoffe sehr, also du weißt, was ich sozialpolitisch und so alles jetzt schlecht ist über Scholz sagen könnte. Habe ich aber jetzt gar keine Lust zu gerade, sondern ich will nochmal ganz deutlich sagen, ich halte Scholz für die geopolitische Lage, für den idealen Kanzler gerade. Ich finde seine Besonnenheit sehr gut. Ich glaube, diese Besonnenheit wird auch wichtig sein in der Konfrontation mit Trump. Das wird nicht mehr so gut funktionieren wie mit Biden, wo beide sehr besonnen aufgetreten sind. Ich glaube aber, dass Scholz hier zeigt, der hat Nerven. Und ich habe große Angst vor einem Kanzler Friedrich Merz, aus sozialpolitischen Gründen natürlich, aus ganz ganz vielen Gründen vor allem aber, weil wir wissen, dass Merz für Taurus Lieferung war, Merz uns noch in andere geopolitische Kriege verwickeln könnte, Merz einen Blick auf den Nord-Ost-Konflikt hat, der so idiotisch ist, dass man es kaum in Worte fassen kann, und dass das mit Merz wirklich eine große Gefahr ist, zumal auch die CDU immer mehr sich versucht, den Republikanern, den Trump-Republikanern anzunähern. Jens Spahn läuft da schon ganz vorn vorweg, und deswegen ist das eine sehr sehr große Gefahr, die sich da gerade ergibt, und deswegen steht ja auch noch im Raum, ob diese Pragmatik, die Scholz jetzt vorschlägt, auch dann in Zusammenarbeit mit der Union wirklich stattfinden kann, oder ob die Union, man hat ja schon Tweets von Spahn und Josef Winkel und so weiter gesehen, Johannes Winkel, ob die Union überhaupt noch bereit ist, eine vernünftige Politik zu machen, etwas Verantwortung zu übernehmen, oder ob die genauso einen Ego-Trip verfolgen werden, wie die FDP das gerade tut.
Sagen wir es mal so, Jens Spahn und Winkel machen jetzt schon einen Wahlkampf, wo Merz noch staatspolitisch verantwortlich Ruhe hält. Ja. Kann sein, dass er nach dem Tweet gestern von Spahn ihn nochmal ein bisschen zurückpfeift oder sowas, aber wir wissen jetzt, in welche Richtung das geht. Wir müssen aber noch einen Schritt zurück machen, denn du hast jetzt schon das Merz, also Black Rock wird Bundeskanzler Szenario. Bis dahin passiert ja etwas. Ja, also bis Mitte Januar. Mitte Januar möchte ja Scholz in der ersten, wie nennt man es, Bundestags-Sitzung dann die Vertrauensfrage stellen. Er hat keine Mehrheit, also wissen wir, okay, dann wird ein Wahltermin bekannt gegeben. Bis dahin. Ich habe hier einen Text heute in der Lesung im Salon, der von drei Personen handelt. Fabian Billing, Michael Briegel und Stefan Scheible. Kennst du einen von den dreien?
Nein.
Wahrscheinlich niemand. Ich kannte sie auch nicht. Ich sagte, wer sie sind, die Deutschland-Chefs von McKinsey, BCG, also der Boston Park Sighting Group und Roland Berger. Das sind die drei größten Berater. Zumindest Roland Berger macht einen Milliardenumsatz. So, nun ist es so, ich wollte diesen Text eigentlich mitbringen, der Unterferner lieven irgendwo im Handelsblatt und so weiter, um mich darüber lustig zu machen. Weil die nämlich mehrere Sachen schreiben, wie zum Beispiel, es braucht jetzt ein Konvent aus Schulz und Schollz und Merz, der noch im November tagt, um bis Jahresende Beschlüsse zu fassen, damit das nächste Jahr gut starten kann. Sie haben sozusagen das Ampelende nicht eingeläutet, aber gesagt, so wird es ja eh nichts. Also sollen Schollz und Merz und dann schreiben sie, und die Regierungschefs der Ampelparteien, jetzt wissen wir, es gibt keine Ampelparteien mehr.
Also der Text ist vor dieser Geschichte erschienen.
Genau, Lindner ist jetzt aussortiert. Und der Text, über den ich mich lustig machen wollte, ist jetzt das wahrscheinlichste Szenario, hinter dem sich Merz und Schollz versammeln könnten, noch im November, um dann kurz vor Weihnachten so einen Plan zu schmieden. Eine der zentralen Aussagen, aber eben nicht nur, ist wirklich Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse. Das heißt, es gibt tatsächlich einen großen Dritten, der jetzt die Agenda vorgibt, und beiden politischen Parteien die Möglichkeit gibt, zu sagen, es ist ja nicht unser Plan, wir machen jetzt keine Zugeständnisse an den, sondern an den großen anderen. Die Vernunft, die Berater haben gesagt, also machen wir das mal.
Und wir haben ja immer gesagt, dass mit der Schuldenbremse ist ganz heikel deshalb, weil man diese Zweidrittelmehrheit braucht.
Ja, die noch da ist.
Die noch da ist, ganz richtig.
Nicht nach der nächsten Bundestag.
Die kann nur jetzt da sein. Nur jetzt kann diese Verbindung entstehen. Und das ist eigentlich jetzt dann das große Glück vielleicht in der Sache. Wer weiß, wohin uns dann dieses Schuldenmachen führt, im Sinne von Aufrichtung oder so. Aber das ist das große Glück dieser Situation, dass Lindner jetzt einfach da raus ist. Und wenn die FDP ja noch ein paar vernünftige Leute hätte, was offenbar nicht der Fall ist, dann würden die ja jetzt eine Rebellion starten gegen Finanzminister Lindner und würde sagen, schau mal, was hast du denn eigentlich angerichtet die ganze Zeit, wir sind aus Landtagen rausgeflogen, wir sind unter fünf Prozent gerade, willst du jetzt wieder einen Schwarz-Weiß-Wahlkampf machen und ein paar markige Slogans im Porsche von dir geben und dann wird das schon was werden. Also es müsste quasi so eine Rebellion der Anständigen in der FDP geben. Ich vermute nur, der Anstand ist so den Verlust nicht gegangen. Verlust, was da nicht mehr viel zu holen ist. Denn dann könnte man tatsächlich die Vertrauenswahl stellen und sagen, ja wir machen es weiter, aber ohne Christian Lindner und ohne vielleicht Stark-Watzinger oder so.
Also mal gucken, ob es jetzt in den nächsten acht Wochen eine mini in zeitlicher Dimension Kroko plötzlich gibt, um noch mal grundlegende Pfeile einzuschlagen und danach erst den offenen Wahlkampf zu erklären. Ich finde, Scholz hat es jetzt gut vorbereitet, dass plötzlich diese drei Beraterchefs da im Hintergrund so eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Keine Ahnung, wie das mit allem zusammenhängt. Es kommt auf jeden Fall aus der falschen Richtung. Wir gehen den Text nachher durch. Das sind insgesamt 93 Seiten, die da geschrieben wurden. Also es ist nicht ohne. Wir gehen aber nur die Handblatt Berichterstattung durch, denn den Originaltext habe ich gar nicht gefunden. Wer weiß, wo der abgeblieben ist. Und genau. Jetzt zu, ah nee, eine Sache will ich noch sagen. Bevor wir jetzt gleich Lindners Personality untersuchen. Es gab gestern Zoff auf Twitter bei der Frage, wie verarbeiten wir das Wahlergebnis in Amerika? Nicht intellektuell, nicht inhaltlich, sondern emotional. Das muss ja irgendwo im moralischen Kompass platziert werden, damit Norden wieder Norden ist und so. Und was ich sehr betrüblich fand, ist, dass ausgerechnet Wolfgang Michael in so einen Tenor einschwangen, der behauptete, alle in der ARD und alle im ZDF hätten dieselben Fehler gemacht wie 2016. Und ich will nochmal umrahmen, 2016 wurde für drei Uhr eine komplett weiblich besetzte Runde als dreiviertel Stunde Panel-Diskussion angesetzt, um abzufeiern, dass Hillary Clinton die Wahl gewinnt. Und es wurde zu Recht danach kritisiert, dass natürlich klar ist, dass Frauen, die relativ wenig mit Politik zu tun haben, sondern aus allen Himmelsrichtungen zusammen, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wo wir in der Runde saßen. Aber es war nicht das Panel, das qualifiziert war, um uns das amerikanische Wahlsystem und den Erfolg von Donald Trump zu erklären. Es gab also ein Misalignment auf Seiten des Journalismus. Das gab es aber diesmal nicht. Und ich will es ganz deutlich sagen, als einer der größten Kritiker dieser Hauptstadt-Journalisten-Produktion, wir haben es im Fernsehpodcast ausführlich begleitet, wir haben es hier auch besprochen. Ich erinnere daran, dass wir selbst im vergangenen Podcast, hier vor einer Woche, die Israel- und Nahostberichterstattung des Heuterschenals und der Tagesthemen nicht schlecht fanden. Denn die Berichterstattung darüber, dass die israelische Armee Palästinenser als menschliche Schutzschilde benutzt und so weiter, kommt aus der ARD direkt, vom ZDF direkt. Das ist zwar keine flächendeckende Berichterstattung, aber punktuell findet das dort statt. Und es ist auch nicht, wie Elmar Thiewissen mal bei uns im Aufmachen Podcast erklärte. Aber wir haben das doch erklärt im Morgenmagazin. Wir hatten doch noch drei Minuten dazu. Nein, das ist Berichterstattung aus Tagesthemen und Heuteschanalen. Also es ist im Inneren Mainstream. So, und jetzt gab es auf Twitter eine Diskussion darüber, wer hat sich hier wie geirrt. Und ich will deswegen nochmal ganz klar markieren, die Präferenz für damals Hillary Clinton, heute Kamala Harris oder Joe Biden, gut, der hat dann auch gewonnen. Aber diese Präferenz für diese Kandidaten ist keine Aussage darüber, wer gewinnt oder irgendeinen emotionalen Ausbruch im Sinne von schon vorab, ja, heute Nacht wird sie ja gewinnen und so weiter. Und dann steht man blöd da, weil man es plötzlich falsch vorausgesagt hat. Die Präferenz für einen spezifischen Kandidaten in der Politik ist als Präferenz immer legitim.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Und ich würde auch sagen, dass es da diesmal eine große Vorsicht gab. Egal, wer befragt wurde, wer wird es.
Ich kann keinen einzigen Namen nennen.
Ich kann dir ein paar Namen nennen, aber das sind ja unverbesserlich. Also Timothy Snyder twitterten in der Nacht, weil wohl also in der Nacht als schon erste Stimmen ausgezählt wurden, dass wohl irgendjemand aus Moskau irgendwelche Trolle behauptet haben, dass da falsch gezählt würde oder so. Das ist ein deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass Trump die Wahl verliert. Die würden jetzt schon anfangen zu betrügen. Und dann kann man sagen, na ja, es war wohl kein deutliches Zeichen dafür. Dann saß nachts auf dem Zeit-Livestream Carolin Emke, die nicht davon ausging, dass Trump gewinnt. Okay, so Einzelbeispiel kann ich jetzt nennen. Was ich aber glaube, und da würde ich sagen, da hat Wolfgang M vielleicht einen Punkt, ist, dass man sich sehr in diese Vorstellung verliebt hatte, dass durch diese Pop-Kultur, die sehr auf Kamala Harris gegangen ist, also Brad Summer, dann Taylor Swift, Swift's Endorsement und so weiter, dass das dazu geführt habe, dass man ein bisschen den Blick verliert darauf, wer denn noch wählt und wer sich einfach davon unberührt fühlt. Also du gehst ja auch nicht los, nur weil du gerne André Rieu hörst und würdest jetzt wählen, wen André Rieu wählt. Also das ist ja, und das ist aber sehr stark, und das ist dann so ein Spiegel-Online-Berichterstattung, die wirklich jedem, der schon mal ein Lied gesungen hat und dann gesagt hat, ich finde Kamala Harris toll, noch mal einen eigenen Artikel gewidmet hat. Und ich glaube, da hat man tatsächlich Fehler wiederholt aus der Clinton-Kampagne damals, wo man auch dachte, naja, also wenn Jane Fonda, Oprah Winfrey und noch irgendeine Sängerin für Hillary Clinton sind, dann ist die Wahl doch so gut wie gerettet. Und das, glaube ich, ist ein generelles Phänomen, weil und das ist vielleicht auch noch mal verstärkt dann eines für Deutschland, weil wir so wenig von dem großen, weiten Amerika kennen. Es ist aber auch ein Problem einfach der Demokraten, dass die Demokraten sich offenbar die Lebenswelt der anderen Amerikaner schwerlich vorstellen können. Also das ist einfach deutlich hier auch zu sehen. Man kann zwar gute Laune verbreiten. Und es war sicherlich auch nicht dumm, das mit diesem Schlagwort weird zu machen. Aber es reicht dann am Ende nicht, wenn Kamala Harris nur anzubieten hat, dass sie nicht Donald Trump ist. Und sie haben Umfragen gehabt zum Thema Gaza. Und sie haben gewusst, dass sie damit Leute verlieren. Und sie haben auch gewusst, dass wenn sie sich anders positioniert hätten, sie nicht stimmen bei denen, die das jetzt gerade ganz gut finden, was Biden da macht, verloren hätten. Die wären dann nicht zu Trump rübergegangen. Da gab es Umfragen. Sie wissen, wie sehr die Inflation die Menschen im Land gebeutelt hat. Also dieses Aufstiegsding. Ja, also diese Erfolgsgeschichte von den beiden Economics, die stimmt zum Teil, aber sie stimmt da nicht, wo man sagen muss, die Verbraucherpreise sind so enorm gestiegen, dass da die Lohnentwicklung bei den unteren 50 Prozent eben nicht entsprechend mitgekommen ist. Und die haben jetzt ein schlechteres Leben unter beiden gehabt. Und die können sich auch nichts dafür kaufen, dass da die große Transformation und Inflation Reduction Act und all das in Gang gesetzt wurden. Und da würde ich schon sagen, ist inhaltlich einfach auch wahnsinnig viel falsch gelaufen. Und deswegen sehe ich da schon ein Problem, wenn gerade auch die deutschen Medien immer wieder gern den Showcharakter bei Trump zwar kritisieren, aber bei Kamala Harris dann wirklich dankbar, jeden, der Schauspieler ist oder Lieder singt, genommen haben, endorst jetzt auch Kamala Harris.
Ich will dem ganz deutlich mal widersprechen. Bitte, mach zu. Es ist nämlich so, also in die Richtung, in die du jetzt abgebogen bist, könnten wir wahrscheinlich aus dem Stand zehn Stunden lang über sowas reden. Also wer hat wo, was und so weiter. Mir ging es aber konkret um, wie ist der Journalismus damit umgegangen. So, aus diesem, also genau diesen Kurzschluss, den will ich jetzt sozusagen entzweien zu sagen, Spiegel Online hat darüber berichtet, wie Taylor Swift Kamala endorst hat. Also hat Spiegel Online damit auch eine Präferenz für nicht nur Kamala Harris, sondern auch, das ist ja voll cool, dass Taylor Swift das gemacht hat. Ich freue mich so als Autor. Ich schreibe das sofort auf für alle Spiegelläser. So, jetzt kann man das kritisieren und sagen, nö, also das hat in diesem Journalismus gar nichts zu suchen. Die Taylor Swift weiß ja, die erreicht ihr Publikum selber. Es braucht dazu gar keine Berichterstattung. Ich würde da sagen, nein, nicht nur will ich alles, was zum Thema Taylor Swift sagt, was zu Kamala Harris jetzt hier nur einmal geäußert, also gab es da drei Texte zu, sondern ich würde es gerne in diese Taylor Lawrence Richtung drehen. Spiegel Online hätte noch viel mehr Berichterstattung machen müssen darüber, was den Wähler bewegt, denn es waren nicht nur Taylor Swift.
Ja genau.
Die Leute haben TikTok hoch und runter.
Aber sie haben ja nur über Taylor Swift gesprochen.
Ja genau, also die Kritik ist dann, aber nicht, die haben zu viel über Taylor Swift Bericht erstattet, sondern nein, Spiegel Online hat für mich zu wenig über Taylor Swift berichtet, zu wenig über alles andere. Also dieses ganze Usermag, wir müssen dahin, wo die Nutzeraugen sind und ja, das ist ein ganz, wie soll man sagen, filigraner, granularer Wahlkampf. Es gab zu wenig Berichterstattung darüber. Deswegen verstehen wir auch heute noch nicht genau, was die Trump-Wähler bewegt haben.
Eine nicht geringe Zahl von Amerikanern googelt, wer eigentlich zur Wahl steht am Tag der Wahl.
Genau, darauf kommen wir gleich noch mal.
So was wäre auch mal interessant.
Also man kann nicht jetzt sagen, es gab zu wenig Berichterstattung zu Donald Trump. Ich habe immer nur Texte gelesen von Taylor Swift oder was auch immer. Ja, es gab von allem zu wenig Berichterstattung. So und jetzt will ich hier mal kurz ein, das ist wirklich hochinteressant, denn es gab sehr viele Podcasts seit gestern. Also im Grunde haben alle Podcasts, die ich so abonniert habe, haben noch meine Sonderfolge gemacht oder was auch immer. Bis hin zu ein Sonderpolitik Podcast live noch über die ARD-Audiothek gestreamt, die 20 Uhr losging und sich eigentlich mit Trump beschäftigte. Und dann kam aber die Ankündigung, dass Schulz jetzt, und dann wurde Schulz noch live mit in diesen Podcast gesendet und so und so. Also es ging alles zusammen. Ich habe noch nirgendwo eine Argumentation gehört, die ich jetzt mal kurz vortragen will. Im Jahr 2000, George W. Bush gegen Elgore. Wir wissen es alle noch. Das musste am Ende Florida ewig lange ausgezählt, da hat der Supreme Court einfach entschieden. Damals stand es in absoluten Stimmen 50,9 Millionen zu 50,4 Millionen. Das haben also knapp über 101 Millionen Menschen gewählt. Vier Jahre später, George W. Bush gegen John Kerry, 62 Millionen zu 59 Millionen. Es gab also auf jeder Seite plötzlich zehn Millionen Wähler mehr. Innerhalb von vier Jahren 20 Millionen Wähler mehr. Das ist die demografische Bewegung in Amerika. Das ist einfach ein Einwanderungsland, ein Land mit ordentlicher Geburtenrate und so weiter und so fort. 2008, Obama gegen John McCain, 69 Millionen gegen 59 Millionen. Also wir sind von El-Gor hatte 50 Millionen, auf acht Jahre später Barack Obama hat 69 Millionen. Das sind fast 50 Prozent mehr Wähler. 2012, wieder 65 Millionen zu 60 Millionen. 2016, 65 Millionen zu 62 Millionen. 2020, Joe Biden, 81 Millionen Wähler. Zu Donald Trump, 74 Millionen Wähler. Also wir haben ungefähr 55 Millionen mehr Wähler innerhalb von 20 Jahren.
Da würde Philip Manow zu sagen, seht ihr, die Demokratie funktioniert doch.
Das ist absolut außer Rand und Band.
Also die Demokratie ist gar nicht in der Krise, weil das wird ja immer gesagt. Und dann würde jetzt jemand wie Philip Manow sagen, naja seht ihr, sie ist nicht in der Krise.
Genau, aber da wurden nicht einfach nur mehr Wähler überzeugt, jetzt auch mal zur Wahl zu gehen. Also 2000 liegen nicht einfach 55 Millionen Menschen zu Hause, sondern die gab es einfach nicht in Amerika. Das ist ein Land im konstanten demografischen Umbruch. Das ist Migrationsadresse Nummer eins für die ganze Welt. Es ist geburtenstark.
Aber die müssen ja auch erst mal wählen können, wenn sie da sind.
Genau, es hat innerpolitische Fliehkräfte durch Urbanisierung, die wir hier in Europa gar nicht kennen. So jetzt habe ich eben gesagt, 81 Millionen Wähler für Joe Biden. Nach einer stetigen Wachstumsgeschichte der demokratischen und republikanischen Wähler. Kamala Harris fehlen 13 Millionen Stimmen im Vergleich zu Biden. Nicht mal Donald Trump kam auf die Zahl vom letzten Mal. Hier muss man jetzt keine Frage stellen, wo sind die Wechselwähler oder sowas.
Sind Leute nicht gegangen?
Hier gibt es keine Wechselwähler. Donald Trump hat wie vorher auch schon sein Wählerpotenzial ausgereizt. Es sind dieselben Leute zur Wahl gegangen wie vorher auch. Nur den Demokraten fehlen 13 Millionen Wähler. Und wenn man sich die demografische Entwicklung anschaut, Amerika ist gewachsen. Also wenn man das gewichtet um das demografische Wachstum, fehlen hier 16, 17 Millionen Wähler.
Die sich sagen, hat eh keinen Zweck, ich bleibe da.
Genau, wir haben es mit Desinteresse, Demobilisierung, Enttäuschung und allem Möglichen zu tun. Und nicht mit irgendeinem Shift zu den Republikanern oder sowas. Nein, die Republikaner haben einfach nur Konstanten. Die haben wahrscheinlich auch Wählerschichten, die demografisch ein bisschen konstanter sind. Die Demokraten nicht. Genau, wir haben hier eine demografische Geschichte, die so immens und so wichtig ist und bislang komplett ausgeblendet ist. Also komplett ausgeblendet, nichts dazugehört.
Und diese 13 bzw. 16 Millionen, wie du dann sagst, die jetzt Kamala Harris nicht bekommen konnte, die also zu Hause geblieben sind, die ja nicht das Land verlassen haben, diese, und darum ging es mir, lassen sich nicht davon locken, dass man sagt, die und die Prominenten unterstützen Kamala Harris. Ich würde sogar... Ja, ja.
Also dazu ganz viele...
Ich würde mich sogar fragen, ob nicht auch einige Endorsements negativ sind. Denn wenn ich sehe, dass Kamala Harris sich in der Vogue ablichten lässt, ich werde heute noch einen Artikel aus der Vogue vorstellen. Also ich habe kein Problem mit der Vogue. Aber wenn ich sehe, okay, da ist die Vogue, dann sehe ich die Superstars, die sich mit Kamala Harris ablichten. Dann weiß ich natürlich, ah ja, ich höre ja schon mal die Musik gerne und die wählen die. Ich weiß aber auch, okay, das ist einfach so eine Welt der Stars. Das hat ja gar nichts mit mir zu tun. Also die Frage ist, ob nicht diese Unterstützung dieser Stars eher einen negativen Effekt hat. Selbst bei den Leuten, die sagen, ja tendenziell finde ich Meryl Streep gut. Aber die hat ja nichts mit meiner Lebenswirklichkeit zu tun.
Was aber unter Strukturphänomenen werden wir ausführlicher dann auch betrachten. Die nächsten Jahre, Danny hat gestern darauf hingewiesen. Jetzt gerade ist auch Halbzeit der Neuen Zwanziger oder dieser Zwanziger Jahre, denn klar zum Jahresende wechselt. Aber wir haben im Dezember 2019 schon die Nullnummer aufgenommen. Also sind wir sozusagen auch ein Monat vorher jetzt im November. Es könnte durchaus sein, dass sich herausstellt, dass Donald Trumps Ansprache, und damit meine ich jetzt das intellektuelle Niveau, das ist das Ziel, das man erreichen muss. Das heißt, ab sofort lautet die Losung nicht mehr Aufklärung, sondern Verpackung der richtigen Idee in der richtigen Sprache. Und das wird die progressive, intellektuelle, wie auch immer man sie beschreibt, wo Geschichte vor sehr grossen Herausforderungen stellen, der man sich aber stellen kann. Ich erinnere daran, dass ich schon nach der Trump-Wahl vor heute, keine Ahnung wann das war, 2016, 2017, bei den Formaten des Politischen war, um in der Bundespressekonferenz, und das ist die Veranstaltung der Deutschlandfunkjournalisten und so weiter, da saß also auch Stefan Dittchen, hat das moderiert, habe ich gesagt, schauen sie sich die Influencer an, schauen sie sich Donald Trump an, schauen sie sich das alles an. Es geht um die Methode. Ja, glauben sie nicht, es geht weiter um inhaltliche Aufklärung, es geht um diese Methode. Wenn sie diese Methode nicht kopieren, haben sie keinen Erfolg. Welche Inhalte sie dann verbritten, ist völlig egal, blenden sie es aus. Es geht erstmal um die Methode. Und Donald Trump hat offenbar, so krass wir das finden, den richtigen Ton getroffen.
Das ist sehr schön, dass du das sagst, denn ich habe vergangenen Montag einen Vortrag an der Uni Düsseldorf über Ideologiekritik gehalten und habe dann erst mal gesagt, was das bei Marx bedeutet, Althusser bedeutet. Und dann habe ich aber auch über realpolitisches gesprochen und habe dann gesagt, na ja, bei Trump ist die Performance besser, habe dann so zwei Videos mal gezeigt, einmal Kamala Harris, einmal Trump, und habe gesagt, inhaltlich reden wir gar nicht darüber, sondern allein die Performance. Und dann kam danach eine sehr kluge Frage, dass es interessant sei, dass ich zum einen Ideologiekritik einfordere und dass er das aufgeklärte Subjekt meint, und wenn ich aber dann über Realpolitik spreche, das so ganz instrumentell sehe und sage, na was funktioniert gerade? Und dann sage ich, ja, ich komme da nicht heraus. Also ich kann natürlich sagen, ich muss jetzt, das ist ja die Idee von Schiller in den Briefen zur ästhetischen Erziehung des Menschen, ich muss jetzt erst ein aufgeklärtes Subjekt herausbilden und dann ist es möglich, die große politische Umwälzung zu machen. Ich sehe nicht, wie das gehen soll. Ich sehe vor allem nicht, wie das bis morgen gehen soll. Also kann ich nur instrumentell umgehen und muss auch feststellen, alle anderen haben und die US-Demokraten haben auch schon längst, vielleicht nicht gut genug, aber haben längst einen instrumentellen Umgang mit der Demokratie. Wer also die Demokratie aus den Sonntagsreden nur kennt, viel Spaß dabei. Nur das hat nichts mit der Wirklichkeit zu tun. Und deswegen muss ich dir leider zustimmen. Also ich wünsche mir natürlich, aber du wünschst es dir ja dem Sinn auch, dass es eine andere Subjektivität gibt, eine aufgeklärtere. Aber wir müssen es in diesem instrumentellen Sinne begreifen. Und das heißt übrigens nicht, dass man jetzt anfangen muss zu lügen und zu betrügen, wie Trump das tut, sondern wir haben ja schon zum Beispiel bei Bernie Sanders jemand gesehen, der also Menschen erreichen konnte, die sich jetzt nicht intellektuell mit Marx auseinandersetzen wollten oder so, aber die wussten, dass es doch gut wäre, ein bisschen mehr Lohn zu haben und wenn die Superreichen was abgeben müssen. Also das heißt, diese Sprache, die dort gefunden werden muss, ist nicht gleich eine, die pure Demagogie meint. Ja, Trump macht uns alle dümmer, aber wir müssen nicht nur mit Blödheit darauf antworten.
Ja, da du es jetzt unter dem Label Wir bedauern das beide, will ich es noch mal kurz ins Positive drehen. Wenn Politik keinen Spaß macht, ist es schlechte Politik. Es muss Spaß machen. Das heißt, man muss einen Modus finden, der nicht nur das Publikum erreicht, sondern bei dem man versteht, warum er das Publikum erreicht. Weil er einem selber Spaß macht.
Das hätte ich gestern übrigens noch schön gefunden, wo du das sagst, die Stimme dir voll und ganz zu. Wenn Olaf Scholz gesagt hat, das waren jetzt drei grästliche Jahre, wir wollen jetzt noch ein bisschen Spaß haben. Und ich lade die Union ein, mit dabei zu sein.
Genau.
Ja.
Wir können jetzt wieder Spaß haben. Diese Trübsinnigkeit haben wir mit Lindner rausgeschmissen. Es ist kein Verlust. Also wir lesen eher das Verlustbuch. Gut, kommen wir zu Lindner.
Biet uns mal die Clips.
Also wir hören einfach diese editorische Notiz von Matze Hilscher selbst, die er noch vorab veröffentlicht, vor dem Gespräch als Einleitung. Denn die bringt uns genau auf den richtigen Track.
Während wir hier saßen, das ist jetzt die zweite Ebene, wurde im Hintergrund sein 18-seitiges Wirtschaftswendenpapier veröffentlicht. Und dieses Wirtschaftswendenpapier ist unter Umständen, so sagt es die Zeitung Die Welt, historisch, weil es sein könnte, dass mit diesem Papier die Ampel nun wirklich auseinanderfällt. Und dass er hier so saß, so ganz ganz locker und über all das gesprochen hat, worüber wir so geredet haben und im Hintergrund so eine Bombe gezündet wird, das finde ich wirklich irgendwie krass. Ich fand es krass auch zum anderen, dass er überhaupt nichts dazu gesagt hat. Also ich glaube, hier wäre auch Rom gewesen, darüber zu sprechen, hätte ich zumindest sehr gern getan. Und dann, dass so einige Aussagen von ihm, gerade auch in Bezug auf Robert Habeck, jetzt ganz ganz anders scheinen. Also das war wirklich wirklich besonders für mich und auch irritierend fühlte sich irgendwie nachhineinlos. Fühlt sich jetzt an, als wäre man irgendwie Teil von irgendwie so einer Hausauf-Karts-Folge gewesen.
Also das Hausauf-Karts-Ding fiel gestern in mehreren Podcasts, dass sich das so angefühlt hat. Ja, da sitzt also einer und sagt, ich liebe meine Frau, während er selber gerade guckt, ob die Post kam, um die Scheidungspapiere auch zu ihr zu bringen. So ungefähr. Und ich habe den Bogen, will ich jetzt mal so bauen, das ist ja ein fast ein zweistündiges Gespräch. Christian Lindner betont nochmal, ich bin natürlich jetzt sensibilisiert für das Thema Familie. Und ich habe auch schon Merz und Scholzens Familienbild eingebaut, nämlich Scholz, der einfach sagt, weil ich Politiker werden will, vereinbare ich mit meiner Frau, dass wir den Kinderwunsch aus unserem Leben aussortieren. Denn Politik und Familie ist unvereinbar. Vergleich dazu, Zitate von Friedrich Merz, übrigens auch bei Marzia Hilscher, wie er sagt, als ich ins Europaparlament gewählt wurde, hatte ich schon ein Kind. Also habe ich meiner Frau gesagt, es tut mir leid, aber ich nehme gerade den familienfeindlichsten Beruf der Welt an. Ich hoffe, wir schaffen es. Und das in Zitaten. Also das sind sozusagen auf Zitat-Ebene. Und jetzt hören wir das Weltbild von Christian Lindner, auf Basis dessen er in die Politik startet. Also das wird man dann auch in meinem Buch noch mal nachlesen, eingeordnet in diese anderen politischen High-Level-Familienbilder.
Mutter, die, meine Eltern haben sich ja sehr früh getrennt. Wie alt warst du da? Da war ich vier, fünf. Und die mir vermittelt hat, wenn man irgendwie seinen Lebensstandard haben will, dann muss man auch was können, was leisten. Und dann ist man unabhängig.
So, man muss was leisten, nur dann ist man unabhängig. Sagt ihm seine Mutter, das heißt, sie reden darüber, welchen Platz findest du in der Welt? Und dann sagt sie, du musst dich unabhängig machen und es geht über deine eigene Leistung.
Ja, also ohne Gesellschaft, ist versuchen zu schaffen.
Ja, so gegen die Gesellschaft. Aber sozusagen, du musst einen Egotrip fahren. Nur so bringst du Unabhängigkeit. Unabhängigkeit ist das Wichtigste. Seine Mutter sagt aber zum Thema Unabhängigkeit, hat sie noch eine zweite Botschaft an ihn.
Das hat mich stark geprägt und in Verbindung dann, aber das ist vielleicht noch wichtig zu in Verbindung damit, dass meine Eltern, meine ganze Familie, auch Großeltern, mir immer signalisiert haben, also du kannst machen, was du willst, wir lieben dich trotzdem. Ja, und das ist enorm wichtig. Warum? Wenn du das Gefühl hast, auch wenn der Himmel über deinem Kopf zusammenbricht und du da scheiterst mit irgendwas, im Zweifel kannst du immer in den Schoß der Familie zurückkriegen.
Die Unabhängigkeit oder die Unabhängigkeitsideologie, die eben eingeimpft wurde, gilt also für alles, außer die Bande zur eigenen Familie.
Und das ist ja exakt der Satz von Margaret Thatcher. Es gibt keine Gesellschaft. Es gibt nur Individuen und deren Familie, fügt sie an.
So, es ist also die Abhängigkeit von der eigenen Familie und die Verlässlichkeit in diese Abhängigkeit. Dort bin ich immer zu Hause. Jetzt würde ich sagen, Politik gibt es überhaupt nur als Antwort auf das Auflösen der Familie als zentrale Instanz. Das ist der moderne Schritt gewesen, der Politik nötig gemacht hat. Man konnte es nicht mehr im Familienverband lösen.
Und eine gute Politik, wie Roosevelt es dann in den 30er Jahren formulierte, wäre eine Politik ohne Angst. Also eine Politik, die nicht darauf setzt, dass Leute in eine permanente Furcht getrieben werden. Eine Politik, die also dahin führt, dass wir frei von der Angst sind und damit hin zu einer Freiheit kommen. Was Christian Lindner hier vorstellt ist, draußen ist die feindliche Welt. Dort muss ich mich behaupten, aber ich kann mich noch auf mich als Individuum zurückziehen, oder die Familie nimmt mich in den Arm. Aber draußen muss schon Angst herrschen. Und ich werde in meiner Politik alles dafür tun, dass diese Angst auch bestehen bleibt.
Und mein Buch läuft ja auch so ein bisschen in dem Tenor, wenn Familie ausfällt, was hier immer häufiger passiert, entweder für die Ehleute, die sich für Familie entschieden haben, oder für die Kinder, die nicht mehr auf finanzielle Ressourcen zurückgreifen können oder was auch immer, muss der Staat einspringen. Das ist die zentrale Aufgabe der Politik, Schutznetz zu sein für diejenigen, die das familiäre nicht mehr vorfinden. Wir haben es hier also nicht einfach nur mit Christian Lindner hat eine andere Meinung oder so, sondern Christian Lindner ist nicht allein mit der politischen Ideengeschichte und ihrem strukturellen Substrat der vergangenen 800 Jahre, seit dem Erfolg der Städtegründung 1900, ja 1300, also im 12. Jahrhundert ging es ja so los, dass sich hier so Zentren durch die Mobilität, so Zentren ergeben haben, wo man so Menschen begegnet, die man nicht kennt. Und mit denen muss man trotzdem klarkommen. Was auch bedeutet, man kennt Menschen nicht, weil man selber auch der Fremde ist. Also man verlässt selber den eigenen Hof, um dann irgendwie 30, 300 oder weiter Kilometer entfernt Business zu machen. So wie verlässt man sich auf Fremde? Na, man hat andere Kommunikationsmedien als einfach nur Liebe, Geborgenheit und was er halt als die große Abhängigkeit von meiner Familie, auf die ich mich immer verlassen kann. Man hat plötzlich sowas wie ein Rechtstitel, ein bisschen Geld in der Hosentasche und sowas. Also es ist einfach völlig offensichtlich plötzlich durch diese Art von Christian Lindner redet mal einen Satz über seine Familie und zack wird völlig klar, wo sein großes Missverständnis ist.
Die Rente ist ja auch etwas, was einen losmacht von der Familie, also dass man nicht sagen muss, ich bin gezwungen, bei meinen Kindern unterm Dach zu leben, weil ich gar kein Geld habe.
Das Rentenversprechen erlöst dich davon, 14 Kinder gebären zu müssen in deiner Lebensphase, um sozusagen nach nigermischen Verhältnissen, auf wen soll ich mich verlassen? Also ich hoffe, meine Kinder haben dann einfach Berufe.
Vor allem, er beschreibt es ja selbst hier so, dass er wohl Glück hatte mit seiner Familie und daraus muss man ja schon Schluss folgern, dass es ja manche dann gibt, die kein Glück mit ihrer Familie haben. Und die haben dann nur noch sich. Der Staat ist es ja nicht, die Gesellschaft kann es nicht sein, dann hat man nur noch sich als Individuum. Blöd, dass man auch noch eine nicht taugliche Familie da hat.
Wenn du Unglück hast mit deiner Familie, begegnest du später nur noch Christian Lindner, der dir die ganze Zeit erklärt, wie unabhängig er ist und dass du ihm egal bist. So, und jetzt schwenkt er aufgrund des Gesprächsverlaufs, aber sozusagen von diesem Familien-Ding, um auf die Ampel wird ja auch immer als Familie beobachtet. In der kämpft er aber, weil er hat ja Ziele.
Das Ziel ist ja nicht zu sagen, jetzt komm, ich bleib stehen, macht euer Zeug allein, sondern neu ansetzen und jetzt weiter geht's und das schaff ich.
Aber was ist das dann, was dir in diesen Momenten hilft? Also ich glaube, jeder und jede, die hier zuhört, kennt Momente des Freitags, fühlt sich an wie Montag.
Mir hilft, mich zu erinnern, warum ich das mache. Ich mache es, weil ich ja inhaltliche Ziele habe.
Die ich zur Not unabhängig und im Kampf gegen die anderen, weil ich mich ja auf meine Familie verlassen kann, so jetzt mal übertrieben, einfach mein particulares Interesse steht über allem. Es gibt kein Gemeinwohl, weil es gibt ja nur sozusagen die Herkunftsfamilie. Er kann es also sehr weit treiben. Und jetzt kommt aber plötzlich er in diese Ampelkonstellation, in der andere auch Ideen haben, die sie vortragen möchten, im Modus des vielleicht nicht ganz so unabhängigen Kampfes, sondern wir machen hier mal Vorschläge auf was auch immer Allgemeinwohlbasis, also ich will jetzt keine Aussage über Habeck treffen, aber Habeck hat ja Paper veröffentlicht, in denen er Vorschläge macht, zu denen sich Lindner, wie er gleich sagt, dann nicht verhelft. Und während wir das hören, erinnern wir uns, hat nicht der Matze Hilscher gerade gesagt, der hat immer so verdächtig auf seine Uhr geguckt, was war denn da los, der wollte gar nicht wissen, wie spät es ist, sondern was melden ihm gerade seine Lakaien, wie läuft es denn mit dem Leak seines Papers. Und im Gespräch, also währenddessen, redet er so.
Ja, der Prozess der Klärung läuft. Wir sprechen ja miteinander.
Ihr redet wirklich miteinander?
Ja, ich sag mal so, ich habe im Sommer auch ein Papier geschrieben zum Thema Wachstum in Deutschland, aber ich habe das im Sommer nicht veröffentlicht. Robert Habeck hat seins veröffentlicht. Und es gab erst die völlig legitime Idee des Kanzlers, zu einem Pakt für Industrie-Arbeitsplätze. Und er spricht ohne Herrn Habeck und mich jetzt mit Unternehmen, Verbänden und Gewerkschaften, habe ich nicht als erster die Idee entwickelt. Und insofern ist die Lage jetzt da. Und die Lage wird jetzt aufgelöst werden müssen.
Also diesen Clip alleine finde ich schon hammerhart, aber diese 14 Sekunden hier?
Nochmal, warum passiert das so öffentlich? Da machst du ja genauso mit wie die anderen im Grunde auch.
Bisher habe ich noch nicht auf Robert Habecks Papier mit einem eigenen Papier geantwortet. Am 1. November.
Während er sein eigenes Papier gerade liegt. In der Sekunde.
Aber in dem Moment funktioniert die Lüge noch und deswegen sagt man sie.
Also soweit darf man Unabhängigkeit einfach nicht treiben. Soweit darf man das Gemeinwohl, und wir kommen nachher im Salon drauf. Es gibt ja auch ein neues Buch von den Aßmanns, Jan und Aleida Aßmann zum Thema Gemeinsinn. Wir kommen darauf zurück. Soweit darf man einfach den Gemeinsinn nicht austreiben. Dass man wirklich nur noch seine eigene, ich kämpfe das jetzt so, ich rede so, während ich zeitgleich ganz anders handle.
Ja, wie gesagt, wir brauchen über Trump nicht mehr dann zu reden. Also wir brauchen, nur weil Trump ein bisschen komisch aussieht und ein bisschen laut ist, brauchen wir es nicht zu tun, als sei das eine andere Kategorie. Nein, das ist so. Wer mit Lindner spricht, spricht mit Trump.
Und jetzt möchte er den Grünen noch eine Idee des Arbeitsmodus austreiben.
Ja, aber das übereinander reden, das macht ja ja alle. Also vor allen Dingen Habeck und du.
Nö, also natürlich, aber.
Aber du weißt ja, wie das wirkt. Das ist ja eigentlich, ich sage ja, also das ist als würden, steht vor der Klasse, stehen drei Lehrer, die sich vor der Klasse streiten.
Naja, Matze, die Grünen haben gesagt, das ist eine Übergangsregierung. Der Kandidat für den grünen Parteivorsitz sagt, es sei gerade die Koalition so wie ein Ehepaar im Trennungsjahr oder man ist nur noch zusammen wegen der Kinder.
Und dann sagt er, nein, wir sind hier keine Ehe, wir sind hier keine Familie. Ich habe meine Familie. Wir sind hier im unabhängigen Kampf. Jeder gegen jeden, jeder für sich.
Und der macht alles richtig.
Ja, also wirklich. Selten hat man eine Ideologie.
Und man sieht ja hier an dem Moderator an Matze, dass er bemüht ist, ihn zu verstehen. Und er macht jedes Angebot, dass man also wir könnten ja so ein Gespräch gar nicht führen. Wir würden nach drei Minuten Lindner auslachen und sagen, verschwinde. Aber Matze macht das zwei Stunden da und wird einfach nur verarscht. Und sagt das ja auch am Anfang. Deswegen hat er ja diese lange Einleitung. Der sagt also, eigentlich ist ja sein, sein, sein Tenor am Anfang. Leute, ich habe schon viele Gespräche geführt, aber so was noch nie.
Ja, er fragt ja immer, ich will wissen, wie Leute ticken. So sagt das ja auch sein Gesprächpartner. Er will also das innermenschliche. Anders traut er sich jetzt hier schon gar nicht mehr ran. Aber er fragt noch mal nach diesem Zwischenmenschlichen.
Nicht so, dass die menschlichen Beziehungen in der Regierung irgendwie nicht intakt wären, dass man nicht miteinander sprechen könnte. Das ist ein falscher Eindruck, weil du bist Rezipient von Medien. Aber wenn ich das mit aller Vorsicht sagen darf, es steht zum Teil auch einfach, ich würde fast sagen, Erfundenes oder Gerüchtemäßiges in den Zeitungen. Und deshalb würde ich sagen, es gibt keine menschlichen, zwischenmenschlichen Hürden für kluge Ergebnisse.
Sagt derjenige, der gestern den gesamten Tag der Bildzeitung durchgestochen hat, und zwar im Minutentakt wohl. Also eigentlich hat die FDP gestern den Live-Ticker der Bildzeitung geschrieben. Aber sonst geht man respektvoll miteinander um, und was die Medien schreiben, ist oft Quatsch.
Die Bild hat ja auch zwischenzeitlich so eine Überschrift, irgendwie so 17 Milliarden Futsch. Lindner scheitert mit Papier und so. Das ist ja auch völlig neben der Spur. Letzter Clip hierzu. Er ist die ganze Zeit von seiner Uhr abgelenkt, wurde dabei gefragt, warum bist du eigentlich Finanzminister?
Der Finanzminister-Posten, das ist ja wahrscheinlich der Posten, der die ja, ich weiß, ich fahre gerade nach Hause, das ist das Gespräch.
Entschuldigung, das war jetzt sehr offensichtlich, der Blick auf die Uhr, sorry.
Aber, ne, ne, der Finanzminister-Posten ist ja eigentlich der Posten, der wahrscheinlich gemacht ist für dich, würde ich behaupten. Also wo man sagt, wenn man... Mach's gern.
Es macht ihm Spaß. Also ich bin sehr dafür. Journalisten sollten immer mal Politiker fragen, ob ihnen das gerade Spaß macht. Weil die Antwort darauf kann vielsagend sein. Weil ich auch meine, es sollte Spaß machen. Ein Kampf gegen alle darf keinen Spaß machen. Wer behauptet, das macht ihm Spaß, muss leider aus...
Rutger Prechmann-Gründen...
.Deviantsgründen entfernt werden aus dem Amt. Wenn Christian Lindner hier am Fazit so eines Gespräches nochmal betont, wie viel Spaß ihm das macht, und wir haben aber gerade gehört, was er da macht, müssen wir sagen, nein. Also das darf einfach prinzipiell nicht sein. Ich bin jetzt nicht dafür, dass man die Kandidaten zwischen Wahl und Annahme der Wahl noch mal einen psychologischen Test, aber es muss journalistisch begleitet werden, was hier los ist. Also wenn die Leute zu sozial gestört sind, also echte Störungsbilder zeigen. Und ich meine nicht die psychologische Diagnose, die natürlich nur psychologische Dienste machen können, aber wenn wir als interessiertes Publikum bei unseren Staatsdienern solche Devianzen feststellen, muss das thematisiert werden.
Ja, ich befürchte allerdings, dass es nicht thematisiert werden wird und ich befürchte auch, dass eine Normalisierung dieser Devianz stattfindet. Die Union geht schon in eine ähnliche Richtung. Auch bei der FDP gab es einmal mehr vernünftige Stimmen und ich bin weit davon entfernt, die FDP an sich zu loben. Aber es gab sie durchaus und es gab liberale, kluge Menschen, die bereit waren, sich auf ein Argument einzulassen und nicht dieses deviante Verhalten nur an den Tag legen. Wenn ich jetzt auf die Wahl blicke in den USA, wo Trump wiedergewählt wurde und wir Äußerungen haben, wie zum Beispiel von Ursula von der Leyen, die nicht nur gratuliert, sondern gleich nochmal betont, wie stark die transatlantische Partnerschaft sein soll und all das, dann merke ich, dass eine Normalisierung der Deviants eigentlich stattfindet. Und man sich dann auch irgendwann fragen muss, wohin führten das noch alles? Also wir können ja jetzt nicht mit Trump gemeinsam sagen, kämpfen wir für die liberale Demokratie gegen die Autokratien. Das ist ja wie mit P. Diddy für Frauenrechte kämpfen. Das kann ja nicht gehen.
Was auch stattfindet demnächst, glaube ich.
Wahrscheinlich kommt das auch noch. Elon Musk wird dann versuchen, P. Diddy zu rehabilitieren oder was auch immer. Also das heißt, da sehe ich, dass das immer mehr in diese Richtung sich bewegt. Und ich finde, dass hier auch mal wirklich eine Selbstkritik stattfinden sollte, von gerade der Ampel, auch von den Grünen, dass man diesen Protektionismus, den Biden abverlangt hat, so klar mitgemacht hat. Denn jetzt haben wir da ein Nest gebaut für Donald Trump, wo er seine Zölle noch weiter auf errichten kann. Und ob man nicht ein bisschen klüger gefahren wäre, hätte man sich mehr mit Macron beschäftigt und überlegt, wie man klug eine Handelspolitik und auch eine Freihandelspolitik gestaltet. Da fällt uns jetzt ganz viel auf die Füße. Ursula von der Leyen sagte damals, als Biden ins Amt gewählt wurde, America is back und Macron war derjenige, der sich traute, im Beisein des Präsidenten zu sagen, fragt sich nur, wie lange. Und diese Frage ist jetzt die, die beantwortet ist. Für kurz war es nur.
Also du hast so einen Drang zu den Inhalten.
Ja, nur ein bisschen Inhalte wollen wir noch machen. Ich habe auch mich gefreut, dass Trump nochmal bei MCA performt hat. Aber das kann ja nicht alles sein.
Ich hatte ja schon beim Blick auf Merz drauf hingewiesen, Merz wird jetzt gewählt. Er ist der Kanzler der nächsten vier Jahre. Sich dagegen aufzunehmen, wir müssen jetzt diese anderen Fragen stellen. Was ist in 15 Jahren? Und als Arbeitsauftrag an die Journalisten, sie müssen sich jetzt darüber verständigen und sei es nur mit sich. Warum machen sie diesen Beruf? Und was fasziniert sie so an dem Gegenstand, die sie beobachten? Und es sind nicht die Inhalte, sondern sie sind fasziniert von der Macht, von der Deviance, die sie nicht verstehen, von diesem Tatendrang, von der Arbeitswut, die da beobachtet wird. Ich würde sozusagen jetzt der Konnex oder der Nexus, der jetzt zu betrachten ist. Warum wird Donald Trump gewählt? Warum wird Christian Lindner gefeuert? Warum geht Kevin Kühnert freiwillig? Warum tritt die grüne Jugend aus? Das ist ein Thema an verschiedenen Problemen, an verschiedenen Ausprägungen. Aber das ist ein Thema und das muss jetzt betrachtet werden. Weil wenn wir einfach nur weiter die Eile gebietet, nicht, dass wir jetzt reflektieren, sondern wir müssen Bericht erstatten, was ist. Und dann schmeißen alle ihre Podcast-Mikrofone an und erklärt mir.
Ja, so ist es ja jetzt auch, dass man dann sagt, naja, aber da hatte Lindner ja schon einen Punkt mit der Schuldenbremse.
Das waren ja schon gestern wieder Berichte. Also mich interessieren jetzt andere Sachen. Und ich finde, alle Leute sollten jetzt sozusagen diese Metaebene mal einnehmen, weil da geht es auch interessant zu. Da erfährt man einiges. Und vielleicht ist dieser Matze Hilscher gar nicht so falsch. Er psychologisiert viel, aber so kann man es auch soziologisieren. Die sozialen Phänomene da anschauen. Und dem sollte man jetzt mal etwas direkter, expliziter nachgehen.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall durch dieses Gespräch der Ideologie und dem Wesen von Christian Lindner näher gekommen, als durch all seine Talkshow-Auftritte. Und das heißt ja etwas.
Ganz genau.
Wir verweisen jetzt auf den Salon. Wer diesen Podcast unterstützen will, kann in den Salon kommen. Und bekommt dann natürlich auch was. Nämlich wir diskutieren Neuerscheinungen. Immer einmal im Monat sprechen wir über ein wichtiges Sachbuch. Und außerdem stellt dann jeder von uns noch fünf wichtige Texte des Monats vor, beziehungsweise ich stelle vier Texte vor und habe wieder einen Hörtipp. Es gibt wieder Musik. Wir wollen ja nicht ganz verzweifeln, also hören wir uns gute Musik an. Das gibt es dann auch wieder. Worüber sprechen wir aber ausführlich heute oder worüber werden wir vielmehr diskutieren? Verlust, ein Grundproblem der Moderne von Andreas Reckwitz. Andreas Reckwitz ist der Soziologe, den auch alle Politiker lesen. Zum Beispiel Friedrich Merz oder auch Robert Habeck. Er hat jetzt ein Buch über den Verlust geschrieben, als etwas, was gerade in der Moderne und spätmoderne wahnsinnig präsent ist. Er fächert das auf. Wir werden diskutieren, ob diese Soziologie uns weiterhilft oder ob wir mit dem Wort nochmal was ganz anderes machen müssen.
Wir sind auch gute, inspirative Leser. Wir müssen nicht jeden Autor für vollnehmen.
Das werden wir also diskutieren. Es ist auf jeden Fall ein Dokument unserer Zeit, dem wir uns stellen. Ich werde dann, wie gesagt, eine CD vorstellen. Streichquartett gibt es da. Dann eine französische Autorin schreibt einen ganz schmalen Roman über einen jungen Russen, Aljosha, der eingezogen wird zum Militärdienst, aber nicht will und er trifft dann in der transsibirischen Eisenbahn auf eine wohlhabende Französin. Und dann ändert sich da manches. Dann habe ich das Buch Fehldiagnose wie Ökonomen die Wirtschaft ruinieren und die Gesellschaft spalten gelesen von dem Ökonomen Tom Krebs. Das ist sehr interessant und ich will nur mal die Aspekte Reallohnverlust und Inflation herausarbeiten, denn das macht der Autor sehr, sehr gut. Außerdem noch ein Text über die Poli Markets. Also es wird ja jetzt gewettet, wer wird der nächste Präsident ist. Wissen wir jetzt inzwischen. Oder auch, wann wird Nasrallah getötet? Geht Israel da und dort hin? Was passiert politisch da und dort als nächstes? Viele Millionen sind da im Spiel und wir sehen dann auch, wer da alles investiert ist, zum Beispiel auch Peter Thiel. Und es wird noch einen kurzen Text über einen TikTok-Trend zum Thema Schlafen geben.
Sehr gut. Der Chefe von Entropic, und ich bin ja ein großer Fan seiner Technik, hat Dario Amodai, der war früher bei OpenAI und jetzt ist er Chefe von Entropic, hat einen zehntausend wortelangen Text darüber geschrieben, was zu erwarten ist. Wir dürfen den auch nicht vervollnehmen, aber wir müssen uns kurz verständigen, was da drin steht. Dann dieses vorher naive Kampfpapier, würde ich sagen, aber jetzt anscheinend Übergangsbrückentechnologie, politische Brückentechnologie der drei Beraterchefs. Dazu zwei Texte. Ich will mal zwei nennen, um sozusagen das eine ist eine Befassung mit worum geht es emotional bei der amerikanischen Wahl und dann ein zweiter Text, worum geht es politisch. Den will ich aber nur kurz nennen. Den muss wirklich jeder selber lesen und ich werde auch sagen, warum, also welcher Quelle er empfohlen wurde. Das ist, wie soll man sagen, da erstellen sich so ein bisschen die ängstlichen Nackenhaare auf. Und am Ende eine Buchempfehlung eines Buches, das ich nicht gelesen habe, sondern es handelt von klassischer Musik. Und es ist so konzipiert, wie klassische Musik konzipiert ist. Man setzt sich nicht hin und liest, also hört sich zehn Konzerte auf einmal an, sondern man geht punktuell rein. Und hier ist besonders interessant, wer dieses Buch geschrieben hat. Denn wir haben ihn schon ein paar Mal erwähnt und man hätte nicht glauben können, dass jetzt plötzlich klassische Musik hier Thema ist. Aber gut.
Ich bin sehr gespannt darauf.
Seid gespannt.
Ich möchte noch kurz ankundigen, dass ich am, ich glaube, 13.11., da ist es, ja am 13.11. in Koblenz zu erleben bin. Da hatte ich einen Vortrag über die kommenden Klassenkämpfe und das gute Leben. Am 17.11. bin ich im Filmmuseum Frankfurt und am 20.11. bin ich an der Uni Köln. Da geht es um die kleinen Holzdiebe. Weitere Termine, ich bin auch noch Anfang Dezember in Zürich. Alles auf meiner Homepage, wolfgangmschmitt.de. Und jetzt musst du noch erklären, wie man dann in den Salon kommt. Der kostet ja 3 Euro im Monat, dann ist man dabei.
neuezwanziger.de, wir sind ein Podcast mit Webseite, über die läuft alles, wie auch der goldene Button in den Salon. Am besten folgt man dem einfach, dann ist man bei Steady, macht sich einen Account und bucht. Man bekommt dann alles. Also inzwischen 9 und, ne warte mal, wir sind ja jetzt wirklich bei 60, 5 Jahre mal 12, also wir sind tatsächlich bei fast 60 Salons. Mehr als 50 Bücher, die wir gemeinsam besprechen, hunderte Bücher, die einzeln besprochen werden. Da kann man alles nachhören. Oder bei Patreon, nicht das ganze Archiv, aber die aktuellen Folgen. Oder bei Apple, der allerkürzeste, die Ein-Click-Lösung. Wenn man eh schon neunzehntgenau bucht, dann macht man es einfach da. Außerdem heute im Salon, wir nennen die vier Termine für die Case nächstes Jahr. Da kann man dann direkt buchen. Also wir verkaufen wieder alle Tickets auf einmal. Das Jahr wird also relativ zügig jetzt gleich weggeverkauft.
Prima, dann sehen wir uns im Salon.
Bis gleich.